hello there today we're going to look at
another paper in the realm of privacy
and language models this time we take
care of text embeddings the paper is
called text embeddings reveal almost as
much as text and is by researchers of
Cornell University the general problem
is this you have a piece of text like
blah blah uh blah and you feed that
through an embedding model like any of
the current Tex text models that exist
and you get out a vector now this is
very often done it's very it's done for
various reasons for example in um
something like clip you embed pictures
and text together so that you can match
the two uh in any text to image model
you first want to embed that text
somehow and in other cases you send that
Vector to a database a vector database
that sort of puts different vectors in
different places and then you can
retrieve with a nearest neighbor
retrieval so let's say your query is
here you retrieve all of these things
this is done for sort of newer Vector
search databases semantic search and
search across modalities the question is
this Vector right here how much
information does it really contain about
the original text if you know anything
about these search databases here you'll
know that what they search are kind of
more the the the semantics behind the
text especially if you do cross modality
search like you search with text for
images you clearly see that they kind of
embed in in the space embed kind of
conception Concepts and things like this
but the actual question is if I just
give you the
vector uh yes you can search for
Concepts but if I give you the vector
how much of the original text can you
actually reconstruct just given the
embedding Vector of that piece of text
and the astonishing part of this paper
is you can actually get pretty far
especially for short texts uh without
having the ability to back propagate
through the model you are able to
reconstruct the large like over
90% uh or in the order of 90% of inputs
exactly or nearly exactly and that is
quite surprising so we'll dive in the
paper isn't too long or too complicated
but I think still think it's uh it's
cool to look at it and it's cool at what
they've done so they say they take they
take a look at the problem of embedding
inversion which means reconstructing the
full text represented in dense text
embeddings they say a naive model uh if
you just train a model to sort of take
an embedding and output a piece of text
performs
poorly but a multi-step method that
iteratively corrects and Reeds the text
is able to recover 92% of 32 token text
inputs exactly and that multi-step
method here is their the method they
propose I think they call it V to text
and that's what we're going to look at
today uh they test on various things and
they test on a data set of clinical
notes they say you know we can recover
things like full names from that data
set of clinical notes which is also
fairly interesting because if we assume
that these vectors sort of represent
Concepts and things that they're trained
on you would expect that you know kind
of the grammar and you know important
nouns and so on are represented in the
Vector but the fact that you can even to
a degree recover things like names uh is
quite astonishing and as we'll see as
we'll see the some of the main effects
here are going to be the fact that the
text is short and the Precision with
which the embeddings are embedded so all
of this comes is not as clear when it
comes to very quantized embeddings which
is often done or when it comes to um
noisy embeddings or and that's also not
something we've seen in this paper maybe
some sort of sparsification or Dimension
reduction is also excluded at least for
now from this type of work so all I'm
meaning to say is that there isn't
really super much evidence for these
this is only an initial step which is
still
interesting so their framing is mostly
in terms of these embedding databases so
something like pine cone is a software
as a service you make a pine cone
database you send your vectors there and
then you can search over them notably
you only send the vectors to Pine Cone
or or to any of these Vector databases
they don't necessarily need the rest uh
I'm think they'd be happy if you send
them the rest but they don't necessarily
need it uh you can just send them the
vectors and then you can query with a
vector and they'll tell you the IDS of
the documents that you get back so you
never have to send the original text and
so that for a lot of people gives them a
degree at least of privacy if you will
where you can say well sure they'll know
what kind of Concepts I have there but
they won't know the exact embeddings uh
the exact text and this paper is
obviously questioning that so can the
thirdparty service reproduce the initial
text given its
embedding so they say the we seek to
generate text such that the text is as
close as possible to a given embedding
our method Vector text uses the
difference between hypothesis embedding
and a ground truth embedding to make
discrete update to the text hypothesis
this we're going to look in the next
page at what exactly that means what
exactly their method is but the result
is that our method can recover 32 token
inputs with a near perfect blow score of
97.3 and can recover
92% of the examples
exactly so what is their method their
method is the following what they want
to do is they want to start with a
hypothesis so I mean uh I guess first
it's it's uh it's important to note what
they're given they're given the
embedding that they want to achieve so
imagine you are your pine cone okay uh
you get an embedding from from you know
some user who sends you their their
Vector you get that embedding and let's
assume you also know what model was used
to compute that embedding okay if not
it's probably going to be one of five
common ones like is going to be one of
the open AI ones or uh one of
the coherer anthropic or one of the
popular hugging face ones so you can
safely assume that for most projects
people don't actually find tune their
own models and therefore you just assume
it's ad to or so okay let's assume you
know that what you want to do with their
method is you want to start out with an
initial hypothesis so the initial
hypothesis you see right here so you
just start out with a guess of text uh
that you then
embed remember you have access to the
model that was used to embed you can't
back propop through it otherwise you
could could just run some sort of
adversarial um attack through the
model but you can use the model to embed
it so you start out with a hypothesis
you send that to open AI yourself and
you get back the embedding and that
might come out to be here now the first
guess is going to be quite a crappy
embedding in fact they show that if you
simply train a model uh to input an
embedding and output a piece of text
then that is going to not work too well
uh but that can be your initial guess
and then you have some sort of procedure
to update that so you start out with x0
or X hat Z which is your initial guess
you embed it to get e hat Z right and
then you observe what's the difference
and I mean that literally what is the
the difference between the two
embeddings between the embedding that
you got from your hypothesis and the
actual ual embedding you want to achieve
and then you take that into account when
generating the next hypothesis so the
thing here on the right is supposed to
show you what is taken into
consideration the target embedding the
previous
hypothesis and the embedding of the
previous hypothesis in fact not only
that but they'll come later to it it's
the embedding of the previous hypothesis
as well as the different
between the two and sure the network
could compute that internally but you
just make it easier by Computing the the
vector difference beforehand and from
that information the network can now
update its guess so it can change the uh
the previous hypothesis here and update
it to get a new
hypothesis in this in our case here this
would mean that the previous hypothesis
the embedding of the previous
hypothesis the target embedding and the
difference between the two they all go
into some sort of neural network and
that's going to be some sort of T5 based
Transformer which is going to give us
the next embed uh the next hypothesis X1
hat we can then use the embedding model
which we have access to right to produce
our next guess which is represented here
and then we just do the whole thing
again so we take
the new embedding of our hypothesis we
take the hypothesis itself we take the
target embedding and we take the
difference between the two and from all
of this we're going to create X2 hat the
new
hypothesis and that by embedding that
will give us the new embedding now we
can even do cheeky things such as only
accept the new embedding uh if it's
actually closer to the Target embedding
than the prev previous embedding right
if not then we can just go back and sort
of try again try to come up with another
new hypothesis and so on so it's an
iterative procedure to get us closer and
closer and closer to the Target right
here um you could probably achieve the
same thing by just kind of moving around
just trying to edit text and see what
the embedding is and then walk closer
and closer and closer it would just take
a lot longer right the hypothesis is
that if your distance in embeddings is
close enough then you will have
reconstructed the text so the the hidden
assumption is that there are no
necessarily no collisions in embedding
space uh which is probably Fair as long
as your input here is some somewhat
grammatical right is somewhat in
distribution for the embedding model and
not just random nonsense um
yeah so that's the the procedure now the
obvious core part is we we can train
easily a model that uh produces that
initial guess here right that initial
guess
and my one note crashed one
second all right we're back you can
easily create a model that gives you
this initial guess right here right all
you do is you take any sort of data set
uh of of a text data set you take a
sample of text you use the embedding
model which you have access to to get
the embeddings for that piece of text
you just do that a whole bunch of times
and you got yourself a data set of
embeddings with corresponding text
inputs and at that point you simply
train a model to take in the embedding
and give you out the piece of text so
that's easy the hard part is obviously
to come up with this this editing model
right here so the model that goes and
takes the previous hypothesis and so on
and the target embedding and the current
embedding and then comes up with a new
hypothesis of what you should do and you
know ideally that new hypothesis is then
better than the old hypothesis uh they
formulate this out right here and I'm
going to jump a whole bunch of um of
notes right here but by the way people
ask me for these notes that very few do
but uh the these are these are a patreon
perk that's a um like it's the only perk
they get uh but I don't know who wants
my notes honestly uh but if you're if
you if you do the papers are obviously
all available and they're Linked In the
description so they formulate this out
right here they say hey if we want if we
have a Target and betting and we want to
generate the next embedding uh this is
this can be split up over the uh across
the sequence of hypotheses every time we
have to uh come up with the previous
hypothesis and then we have to edit that
hypothesis to make the new hypothesis
and uh the editing process so you can
see this all this marginalizes
essentially out across this thing right
here and this thing is obviously a
derived quantity from this thing uh so
um yeah here so there's two component
components one is the initial embedding
and one is this editing model right
here they say okay what we do is the
following we train the model by first
generating initial hypothesis from the
model in section 31 section 31 is is
just the the simple model I described
before
right and then training a model on this
generated data so all they do is they
take the model I just described here the
basic inversion model then uh they take
a set of embeddings right so you have
like set of embeddings embeddings
embeddings embeddings you use this model
here to create the um to create the
approximate texts from those embeddings
so the these would all be x z here I
call them t0 but these would all be the
initial guesses and since you know what
the original text was to do the
embedding then you have essentially all
that you need so this is this here these
are the same um you know the original
text you know
the the initial hypothesis and from this
you can also generate by embedding you
can generate e0 so now you have
everything that you need to train a
model to generate the to generate the
very first step of the procedure right
because we've trained a model to
generate the zeroth step the initial
hypothesis and now we can now we have
all the data that we need to generate
the first step the first step being I
have an initial hypothesis
what should I edit it to so you take a
model that you
input uh the embedding you want to reach
t0 e0 possibly the difference between
the two and you go for T the original
text now you can imagine this going on
and saying okay this here will
ultimately result in a model that um
let's call that M1 or we call this here
m0 this here will result in a model that
can do that first step what we can then
again do is we can again take the
original text the original embedding or
we can take the original
text no not the original
text we can take the original
[Music]
embedding h no obviously we're we're
going to take this text right here we're
going to feed it through M we're going
to get the T1 hat uh and then we can do
the whole thing again right we can take
this the original text the original
embedding
and E1 hat derived from T1 hat and
create a data set to create M2 so a
model that does the second step of the
whole
process and we could do that for as many
steps as we like so essentially for for
each model creating a for each step in
the inversion process uh creating a
separate
model we've already seen things like
this in diffusion like diffusion models
image diffusion models and so on and
people there they have helped themselves
by saying instead of training one model
for each step how about we train a model
that takes all of the inputs and then
simply takes a parameter T here uh
lowercase T that indicat Ates the time
step right T is zero for the first Model
T is one for the Second Step T is two
for the third step and we just generate
a giant data set and train uh the same
parameters but T is just a parameter
that works for diffusion models in this
paper they go even simpler and they just
say whatever we just train that first
step here we just train this one so we
generate the initial hypothesis and then
we train a model to just from the
initial hypothesis create the original
text directly and that's enough even for
hypothesis number five uh we can use
that model now obviously that doesn't
really match the distribution that
you'll get later on when you do the
multi-step procedure that we saw over
here but it seems to be good enough for
them and it seems to work uh and yeah
you always like the sneaky Advantage you
have right here is that you know the
Target and you can always check whether
the new embedding of the or the
embedding of the new Step that you've
made is closer in embedding space than
the old one and if not reject it so you
essentially have this uh very accurate
guiding principle that helps you and all
the all of this all that this model here
has to do is give you
variation like it's essentially instead
of walking around randomly in certain
space it gives you an approximate
direction to walk around but you always
have a very solid Criterium to reject or
to go towards and therefore this model
doesn't need to be you know super duper
duper good and uh yeah yeah so it just
needs to call down the search space
enough and that seems to happen so
that's what this paper does it just
trains a
onestep uh procedure to reconstruct the
original text and then it uses that to
nudge uh the text iteratively into a
good direction and according to their
experiments what's really important in
this procedure is that you have these
these embeddings from the current
hypothesis be part of the input so that
once you generate a hypothesis you
actually embed that hypothesis and get
back where in embedding space you
currently are and what the difference
between the current embeddings and the
target embeddings are because that can
help you a lot uh coming up with the
next hypothesis and without going
through much of the text that is almost
all of the method here um yeah they have
a paragraph against how exactly they put
the embeddings into the form so that
they would fit into a Transformer but um
yeah to me that's a bit of a technical
detail now the results here we've
already gone over in the introduction
but essentially uh for for data sets
such as Ms Marco natural questions for
models such as GTR and the open AI API
they are able to reconstruct a ton of
text so you can see right here
92% exact match as 97 blow score that's
50 steps of reconstruction plus beam
search uh so beam search send tends to
help a lot too and again right it's it's
a search problem with a very accurate
estimator of whether you're on the
correct path and all you need is
something to kind of guide you in the
correct direction and when you're able
to reject stuff if you go away you and
you have a beam search that lets you
kind of explore different paths to your
goal that is massively helpful so it is
surprising how much information there is
in these embeddings but the same time
it's also not that surprising that if
you know the information is there you
will be able to reconstruct it with a
method like this still the numbers are
are pretty high and that's astounding so
here you
see uh it's it works but it works it it
works less a bit less with the um M
Marco data set and the open AI API not
exactly sure how many dimensions GTR has
something that this paper doesn't really
investigate is how how the
dimensionality of embeddings influences
this uh which would be interesting to
know what it does investigate a little
bit is the length of the sequences so
here you always have 32 token sequences
and here on average you can see you have
uh a bit more and when you have a bit
more or when they make the data set have
a bit more you can see that the
Reconstruction performance drops uh
dramatically not you can still
reconstruct stuff but it drops even
though right even though the cosine
similarity of the embeddings that is how
cosine similarity is um is also very
high and yeah that tells you that maybe
for longer sequences the exact text
isn't as much represented anymore in
these embeddings as for short text also
here you can see this table this is now
out of distribution so the previous
table they have trained on these models
on these uh data sets as far as I'm
aware or on the training sets um this
here is out of distribution so things
they haven't trained on and you can see
the performance is still very very good
uh so the where the base model achieves
36 blow DET text achieves 95 blow and so
on but as we go down here and the
sequences get longer and longer you can
see the performance dropping uh dropping
being less being less being less not
monotonically uh but you know kind of
degrading as the sequences get longer
which is fine and and they're still much
much higher than the simple base model
trying to oneshot invert the uh the
embeddings so that is and yeah the
difference is even more pronounced in
Long embeddings right the difference
between the the one shot and the
multi-shot yes in domain able to recover
77% of blow in just five rounds of
Correction uh out of domain is able to
exactly recover 66% of examples this is
these are still really high numbers
right so don't get me wrong here they do
an investigation into clinical notes and
what I found uh interesting is that they
were able to recover 94% of first names
95% of last names and
89% of full names while recovering 26%
of the documents exactly so even things
like names which you would expect to be
you know not as well represented in
these embedding vectors
um are can be recovered quite with quite
high accuracy now one thing that could
shed a bit of light here on what's going
on is this investigation which is really
cool that they did so what they said is
how about we add some noise onto these
embeddings right can we add noise and it
therefore destroy the ability
of any person or any attacker to
reconstruct the exact text now obviously
the answer is yes uh depending on the
level of noise but as you up the noise
certainly at some point the embeddings
will have no longer the information to
reconstruct the text however you have to
select a level of noise so that they're
still useful to the tasks that you want
to do with them and in this case the
framing of this paper the task is Vector
retrieval
so they ask is there a level of noise
where
reconstruction uh potential is low but
retrieval quality is still high and the
answer is yes so you can see the
intermediate level of noise here is
where the
Reconstruction ability drops drastically
but the retrieval aspect uh stays high
and only later does retrieval suffer as
well
so what I can imagine this means is that
the vectors of embedding model their
lower frequencies which is their their
more you know meaningful components if
you will they probably largely capture
these more retrieval relevant semantic
things and and and uh things that
actually make a difference in meaning
whereas the higher frequency components
may be used used to store the minute
details of the exact sentences we've
seen this also with image models and so
on adversarial examples are bugs not
features and things like this they a lot
of um lot of places have discovered or
or reported on this that models will use
different parts either of the frequency
spectrum or um of the parameter space so
on to encode different types of
information and when you go start
pruning and culling down or quantizing
or noising things you will not uniformly
destroy information and that's what
seems to be the case right here so the
high frequency you know minute details
in the embeddings are probably
representative of the exact text things
like you know which exact token was used
here and there and if you destroy the
high frequency part and that's exact L
What You Do by adding gaussian noise
right you con you it's like a
convolution with a a gaussian kernel you
sort of smoothing everything a bit you
lose these things first and yeah that I
find quite
interesting um they make some other
investigations very interesting all of
that uh so and the last thing that I
found interesting is that they
experiment with this initial hypothesis
and they find that even if they uh put
some random tokens or they just put the
word the or they just put some sentence
they found somewhere it essentially
works as well as if they generate the
initial hypothesis with their base model
so their iterative procedure is able to
very quickly escape from very bad
initializations which again speaks to
the fact that they probably did a did
did well uh training that model and it's
completely fine to only train the
onestep model at least in this case they
have a few examples as well however yeah
there are a few and they have they have
good section on
limitations um one is obviously adaptive
attacks and defenses so the thing where
they add noise this is an explored Topic
in the area of adversarial examples uh
to just add noise and that kind of
destroys the adversarialness of any or
potential adversarialness of any
examples so if you get an adversarial
example or if you have a service where
you classify images you can just kind of
add noise and um that will still allow
you to classify it but it will make
adversarial examples be less effective
however if an attacker knows you're
doing that they can take that into
account when crafting the adversarial
examples and therefore again be very
effective uh so this paper doesn't
investigate what happens if an attacker
who wants to reconstruct text takes into
account that there could be noise on the
vectors so that's for one for the other
dimensionality of embeddings isn't
really explored length is explored in a
a tiny bit of a degree um and if you if
you think about it then let's say so
they have 32 tokens here right 32 tokens
into What's the vocabulary size usually
the vocabulary size is like 32k right
which is like two to the 15 okay so
there are with a fif 15 bit
um I have 32 * 15 bit 32 is what 2 to
the that's 2 to the 8 No 2 to the 5 2 4
8 16 32 2 to the 5 okay so I have uh
essentially a 32 token sequence is
essentially 20 bit of
information now the open AI a 2 model is
what it has
1,53 something like this right so it's
it's uh 64 * 24 no yeah I think so let's
quickly
check six yeah that that kind of makes
sense um so they have this is 2 to the
6 this is 2 to
the five this is not two to the anything
um so this is six bit six bit this is uh
two to the
4.5 this is like 10.5
bit um no no no no
sorry that that that makes no sense uh
because these are floats so let's assume
that for any reasonableness we quantize
so quantization is also something that's
not explored in the paper which would
also be really interesting to look at
what I feel what I'm trying to get at
here is that maybe you know the there is
some length where the embedding Vector
just given by the dimensionality of it
is complet complely capable of holding
all the information uh even when you
don't when you are very course in what
you do so let's assume we quantize to
four bit right so each of these things
actually has four four bit of
information or two bit right every every
position only has four different states
so let's say there's two
bit um two is a bit two is a bit rash
four four bit 16 different states
uh so there are there's 64 * 24 * 4 bit
that can you know that are potentially
inside of this Vector you can see
already the difference here I believe
did I do something
wrong
maybe well in any case I feel for 32
token sequence for 32
token length sequences it's well enough
uh to use an embedding Vector of
right I mean we can calculate in another
way what does it mean it means
essentially that you have 2 * 24 that's
48 Dimensions per token so every token
has 48 Dimensions that can potentially
represent it and you only need to index
32,000 things so you only need 15 bit
but you have 48 floating Point
Dimensions now we can calculate what if
this is
64 what if the length is 64 ah well
then uh this here divides by two so you
only get 24 Dimensions that already gets
critical what if it's
128 you only now have
12 and you have 12 Dimensions to
represent an index into a 15 bit set and
that's where it starts to get critical
right and that's why probably once you
go to 128 it starts to get critical
because you can no longer represent
everything If This Were binary now this
is still a float but as you go up here
with the length you go down here and all
of a sudden at 1,000 24 you're left with
only two bit two two Dimensions or one
dimension or something like this and
with two or one floating Point number
you're no longer able to represent this
here so you have to start to compress
and that's where we get the effect that
maybe at those points you're no longer
able to rec to reconstruct really
exactly what happened there sorry for
the bit of of shady math but my point
essentially was that 32 tokens length
you have plenty plenty of Dimensions per
token to represent its index in a
vocabulary uh but uh the higher up you
go with the sequence length the
more uh inconceivable that becomes and
the more you have to rely on actually
learning grammar learning frequencies
learning Concepts and so on in order to
bring down the loss during training all
right math rant over that was it for me
for this paper there's lots of more
information in here so give it a read
and yeah I'll see you around bye-bye